lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
hablar sobre dinero en particular
hablaremos del mercado de dinero y esto
podría parecer un poco contra intuitivo
porque estamos acostumbrados a pensar
sobre el mercado para otras cosas y
usamos el dinero para pensar en los
precios y así facilitar las
transacciones pero ahora el mercado es
de dinero en sí mismo así que la primera
pregunta es de qué manera podemos llegar
a un costo del dinero para ayudarnos con
eso haremos un experimento mental
digamos que tenemos un mundo muy simple
en el cual tenemos dos opciones podrías
tener dinero en efectivo podrías tener
100 pesos en efectivo como esto o
podrías prestar 100 pesos al gobierno y
el gobierno te devolverá a 101 pesos en
un mes entonces nuestra opción la
llamaremos bono un bono que en realidad
estás prestando en esta situación estás
prestando este dinero al gobierno
supongamos que no hay riesgo que el
gobierno es bueno con el dinero y estás
seguro de que te lo devolverá
también podrías tener bonos de otras
entidades como estados o empresas pero
digamos que este es un bono del gobierno
federal que cuesta 100 pesos y que en un
mes el gobierno te lo va a pagar en 101
pesos así que mi pregunta es si en lugar
de comprar este bono y que el gobierno
te pague 101 en un mes si en lugar de
eso piensas oye eso suena interesante
pero me gusta tener el dinero en
efectivo cuál es el costo de oportunidad
de mantener el efectivo pausa el vídeo y
piensa en esto bueno si decides quedarte
con el efectivo en lugar de comprar este
bono del gobierno en lugar de prestarle
al gobierno por un mes estarás perdiendo
un peso entonces tu costo de oportunidad
justo aquí podrías verlo como un peso
durante el mes o si piensas en términos
de cuánto dinero prestaste esto es un
costo de oportunidad de 1% costo de
oportunidad
y como estamos a punto de ver pensamos
en el costo de oportunidad de tener el
dinero como su costo de oportunidad en
el mercado de dinero entonces voy a
dibujar unos ejes por aquí para empezar
a pensar en el mercado de dinero está
bien así que llamemos a este eje
vertical la tasa de interés nominal tasa
de interés nominal algunas veces lo
verás como 'the y en su abreviatura pero
lo escribiremos completo este eje es la
tasa de interés nominal y la razón de
que me esté enfocando en la tasa de
interés nominal es que en esta situación
no conocemos cuál es la inflación no
sabemos cómo calcular la tasa de interés
real en esta situación y es lo que la
gente busca cuando tiene que tomar
decisiones
la gente no está calculando
constantemente la tasa de interés real
porque sabe exactamente cuál es la
inflación en ese momento ellos pueden
decir oye podría quedarme con estos 100
pesos en mi cartera o podría prestarse
los al gobierno y un mes después obtener
101 pesos así que vamos a tener una tasa
de interés nominal en este eje justo
aquí
luego en el eje horizontal voy a tener
la cantidad de dinero cantidad de dinero
hay muchas maneras de pensar en la
oferta monetaria lo vamos a ver en
vídeos futuros pero llegaremos a eso en
un segundo lo primero que quiero hacer
es construir una curva de demanda de
dinero así que déjenme hacerles una
pregunta si las tasas de interés nominal
son realmente altas tanto que en lugar
de obtener 101 pesos después de un mes
digamos algo extremo si obtuviera 200
pesos en un mes querrías quedarte con
los 100 pesos en efectivo o dirías oye
no prefiero prestarle ese dinero al
gobierno bueno si el sentido común os
diría que si la tasa de interés nominal
es muy alta entonces la gente tal vez
elegiría renunciar a quedarse con dinero
y así la cantidad de dinero podría ser
menor podríamos estar en una situación
como la siguiente si la tasa de interés
nominal es alta hay un gran costo de
oportunidad por quedarse con ese
efectivo probablemente querría
prestárselo al gobierno oa alguien más
ahora qué pasa si la tasa de interés
nominal es realmente baja digamos que el
gobierno diría oye nos presta usted si
empezó esa hora y en un mes de regreso
100 pesos y una décima parte de un
centavo entonces tú dirías algo así como
eso no tiene sentido
en realidad me gustaría quedarme con mis
100 pesos probablemente los necesite
probablemente tenga que hacer algunas
transacciones con ellos probablemente
prefiera tenerlos por ahí por si el
sistema de cajeros automáticos se apaga
hay un huracán o cualquier cosa que pase
entonces una tasa de interés nominal
baja hace que tenga sentido que la gente
prefiera tener el efectivo así tendrás
una mayor cantidad de dinero eso explica
por qué los economistas suponen que la
curva de demanda de dinero muchas veces
abreviada dm está inclinada hacia abajo
es decir con pendiente negativa y si
queremos ser un poco más técnicos con
algunos términos que probablemente viste
en una clase de economía el economista
famoso john maynard keynes presentó tres
motivos particulares para explicar
porque esta curva está inclinada hacia
abajo algunos de los cuales ya hemos
mencionado al primero lo llamo motivo
transacción transacción y es una de las
principales razones por las que quieres
mantener el efectivo y la idea es porque
probablemente lo tengas que usar si
quieres comprar una barra de dulce o una
iguana de mascota necesitas ese dinero
si lo has prestado al gobierno y de
repente ves a la iguana de tus sueños
entonces tendrías que esperar un mes
para comprarla ese sería el motivo
transacción una razón una motivación
para tener el dinero pero una vez más la
razón por la que tenemos esta curva
inclinada hacia abajo es que si la tasa
de interés nominal es realmente alta si
el gobierno te quiere pagar más en un
mes entonces tal vez dirías sabes que
quiero correr el riesgo inclusive si veo
la iguana de mis sueños si le prestó el
dinero al gobierno ahora tal vez en un
mes pueda comprar dos iguanas aunque no
sean como la de mis sueños y por otro
lado si la tasa de interés nominal se va
muy abajo podrías decir bueno sabes qué
y no hay razón para tomar el riesgo de
no poder comprar la iguana perfecta
cuando la vea así que no voy a prestar
el dinero al gobierno entonces más gente
se quedará con el dinero en sus
bolsillos otro motivo del que habla
kanes es el motivo precaución y la idea
es que tengas el dinero disponible en
caso de una emergencia digamos que se va
la luz que hay un terremoto que hay un
huracán que el sistema de cajeros
automáticos se apaga tal vez hay un día
feriado y el banco cierra por alguna
razón y necesitas tener dinero en
efectivo para hacer algunas
transacciones pero una vez más es más
precautorio para ese día lluvioso para
esa mala situación y una vez más y las
tasas de interés nominal son altas
probablemente dirías bueno si quiero ser
precavido pero puedo obtener más dinero
si lo presto pero si las tasas de
interés nominal son bajas dirías no vale
la pena prefiero quedarme con algo de
dinero mucha gente hace esto y en
general esa es la razón por la que en
una economía se va a determinar la
cantidad de dinero
ahora el último motivo del que hablo
kanes es el motivo especulación
y la especulación en general es esta
idea de comprar algo o vender algo o
esperar a comprar algo con base en la
especulación que haces sobre si el
precio subirá o bajará entonces por
ejemplo podrías decir oye si espera un
par de días o tal vez si espera una
semana probablemente obtenga un mejor
acuerdo con el gobierno así que déjame
quedarme con esto en suma cuando las
tasas de interés son altas las personas
pueden estar dispuestas a renunciar a la
especulación y cuando los intereses son
bajos probablemente dirían sabes que voy
a quedarme con mi efectivo por ahora
porque no hay mucho que ganar si prestó
el dinero hasta el próximo vídeo